well it's great to be here thanks for
having me the PM in the heart of the
White House hearty handshakes and warm
Smiles it's a special relationship
[Music]
s
a thumbs up for Mr sunac and the special
relationship these two leaders here to
talk about deeper economic ties packaged
up as the Atlantic declaration there's
no issue of global appoint of importance
none that where our nations are not
leading together countries like China
and Russia are willing to manipulate and
exploit our openness they will not
succeed today we have agreed the
Atlantic declaration
a new economic partnership for a new age
of a kind that has never been agreed
before an agreement to ease some trade
barriers Titan defense industry ties and
share more data all with an eye on
emerging threats and on AI where the
Prime Minister wants to show leadership
a very welcome POTUS endorsement we're
looking to uh Great Britain to help lead
that effort to figure out a way through
this so we're in full total cooperation
because there's no one no country we
have greater faith in being able to
negotiate this both leaders talking up
the Atlantic declaration but that Accord
is nowhere near the full fat free trade
deal that the British people were
promised as a brexit bonus in the 2019
conservative Manifesto it was meant to
have been completed by 2022 instead that
free trade deal has been put very much
on ice
that calling in what is otherwise a warm
relationship undoubtedly uncomfortable
for Mr sunac that is a broken promise
I've got what you said in the manifesto
here you stood on it since then we've
had a pandemic we've had a war in
Ukraine and that has changed the
macroeconomic situation see you have the
British people well I think Trump is
with other countries I said but we've
grown our trade with America by 20 last
year 14 billion pounds of investment
supporting thousands of jobs announced
just yesterday the real challenge we
Face are the threats to our Economic
Security taking steps to forge closer
ties in a destabilized world but that
trade Deal's still elusive the UK may be
Biden's closest Ally but for this
President America comes first Beth Rigby
Sky News in Washington